Hello.
My name is Brian and today we are going to talk about introductions and making friends.
An introduction is when you introduce yourself to someone.
Usually the other person will also introduce themselves as well.
Hi, my name is Brian.
Nice to meet you.
What's your name?
My name is Joey.
When you make a new friend or when you see somebody you know,...
...you may want to shake hands.
You will then have a conversation with the person.
I am going to show you how it is done.
Do you go to school here?
Yes.
I am in Mrs. Guzman's class.
What class are you in?
I am in Mrs. Pollard's class.
She is nice.
Do you like her class?
Yeah, she is cool.
Now I am going to invite Joey to play on the playground.
You don't have to do this.
You may say something like, "Nice to meet you. See you around," and walk away.
Or you can say, "See you around. Maybe we can hang out some time."
For our demonstration, I am going to invite Joey to play.
Do you want to play with me on the playground?
Sure.
Let's go.
It was fun playing with you.
We should be friends.
I would love to be your friend.
See you tomorrow.